hi Hey
if people are watching this Mary you're
probably in Australia by this point oh
yeah I am going to Australia to host
some twitch stuff for Australia
well we're recording this before you go
but at this moment when people are
watching this Saturday I plan on beating
this [ __ ] before I leave
yeah so this could be the final episode
I'm gonna switch over right now I do pip
always be forgetten ABF you know me cool
so we're in last chapter of Chris and
piers Pierce's
yeah thus the last chapter of our
original six campaign I know some there
were some people who were saying they
would like to see us do Jake and
Sherry's campaign I think there is a
majority it we just want to see us play
seven and we could save the Jake and
cherry thing for if we ever go back to
do bonus things like Leon B scenario or
I've had so many people ask before I
feel very strongly that we should use
that games stuff like it I think seven
will be a good segue back to code
Veronica because Co Veronica's got this
gut check with a tyrant or think that
you can really screw yourself over so
and I've only ever beaten it once cool
yeah hopefully we'll be six in this
episode hi captain
time do we start
speaking of did we get that cutscene all
right No
so they landed on the jet and then took
this elevator down to an underwater or
like sorry oil refinery we were planning
on showing you we even tried restarting
but we instead we got the checkpoint
right after that so when we press
Continue can I think I got it yeah one
of them nonchalantly be like differ from
the lord who look like you've seen a
ghost
dude that's totally something she would
do yeah when the dude sniper in the
stomach from the helicopter what did she
say
well played you got me yeah something
like this is unexpected
well yeah to my twitch oh you want to my
foot wait a minute other way no he's my
choice yay I'm so nimble Invents you
like you shouldn't be able to turn
around so easily in here I know he's an
otter this would be a little man you are
with a hell of a tush it's gonna be kind
of sad going back to just keep playing
and watching although I'm looking
forward to seven why because that's the
first first game will be playing this
series since resonable for that's and
you had the awesome game it's like fresh
in your mind it'll be I think good for
you because they'll actively know
whether or not to help me or yeah I'm
also gonna I'm gonna take the
opportunity to play through in VR which
okay so I think we decided we're not
going to for you because it'd be weird
it'd be weird having you on VR in this
room and the movement removed from you I
feel like I'll just if I would have to
guide you at all which I don't think I
have to guide you it's it's a hard game
it can be hard but it's like
well-designed so it's not holding your
hand that's cool but it's guiding you
through in the good way place your honor
who you are or on madhouse typical you
can survive there to refresh my memory a
beat it twice and it's about 16 hours
I'd say it's like raising will for
length
I think memory serves
Roger Bob are these weird guys ones on a
turret oh yeah
oh there's two turrets holy [ __ ] oh my
god
soon to be
um one of the RP am I supposed to be
able to get up there where you're
friendly one of the turret guys
our peach did you go up I went down it's
not pretty good tweet today someone was
saying if you want to look like a badass
on your first date hire a friend to sit
outside the restaurant just keep a laser
pointed at you the whole time
and while Chris's turnaround from this
angry drunk in like one cutscene to
supportive actual Captain Awesome yeah
it kind of is actually indicative of my
real-world relationship with you I hate
you most the time but every once in a
while will shine through but I'm your
superior so you have to do what I say
yes oh shoot yeah exactly I didn't
really get that joke until now well oh
[ __ ]
I'm getting tossed around like a
Thanksgiving turkey that's the metaphor
right yes who's that guy oh my god I'm
getting stuff like a Christmas tree all
right
oh gosh what getting bum-rushed you
gettin slapped around like a Christmas
ham yes that restored power to the
elevator meaning for those two okay this
guy with the RPG just needs to [ __ ] off
sounds like you're having a lot going on
over there I'm in a basement yeah what
am i what am i you know my end game
right now it elevator piers I'm in the
elevator headed your way
this movie I Adele view Oh shot you in
the face
it was like all this action happening on
your end hi hi
third floor menswear six la home and
garden
here's needs a new crock-pot peers
wait there's ammo over here Oh for me oh
there was for me too you're surprisingly
restrained with the circle budgetary
it's waiting me out
sweet [ __ ] wait a minute I know what to
do
giant oh [ __ ] I missed all right maggot
holding guy
it's grenade launchers too fun
it's just a blast Oh exploded hey hi hey
I got the door it keeps opening and
closing Oh
burning out his fuse up here what's the
deal with these guys are they a big
giant pincer
oh those pincher bugs oh look at look at
look at oh you missed it
oh you oh you ripped off his one of his
pinchy I don't know why I assumed you
weren't looking this sick
good presentation they're dead No hey
yeah guess what game I play until 3:00
a.m. last name kind of finally get why
people love it
what was your give me year last year I
think I played it on switch it recently
came to switch this week Oh star do you
yeah 2015 that was stupid last year I
think I'm pretty sure either way I
finally I get it I am hooked I know it's
super good isn't it yeah once I stopped
worrying about like doing it the right
way and just playing however I wanted
that was key yeah I mean there are
things you could screw up but it's never
gonna like harshly penalize you it's not
detrimental to you
I mean obviously like certain crop you
want to have a green house before winter
and stuff like that but like still
pretty relaxed and lets you go about
your business gosh it's so it's such a
wonderful escape reality it's such and
I'm thoroughly enjoying even more
because it's on the switch I just laid
in bed and then I looked over in those 3
a.m. that was me a lot too because you
have to finish the day for it to save
yeah and then when you get up you're
like alright I might as well go water my
strawberry bushes and my strawberry
plants and harvest some legumes and
maybe finish building that chicken coop
I'm just I'm actually just starting to
like get animals what are we supposed to
be doing I'm not sure I was I think
you're in the right spot yeah I hear
elevator captain yes I know starter
belly's not related to resonate with I
play other games it's related in the
sense that it's something you're playing
yeah
and I'm glad you're enjoying it I mean I
tried it before it I believe in that
game like full-heartedly so it's
wonderful to like listen to somebody
else who's also excited about it yeah
John Liu from Calendar teens about love
it a lot of people think yeah and it
makes sense now but like for a while
it's also the perfect game to play in
between all the other games I'm trying
to finish Oh
boogers hey it's guys up top boogers
just hats on my bottom
oh [ __ ] okay we should I could have
killed you
Wow there are a lot of people we're not
a de
whoever it is talking spiking the volume
I got nother one next oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah come on come part yeah I
got start with tickets well I think our
entire team did yeah yeah I didn't but
like I got to my girlfriend and I are
gonna go to a 1:00 a.m. showing which is
perfect because the people who are going
to midnight will not have gone now yet
and spoil it I'll still be in the
theater when they're like tweeting
whatnot but like all the midnight
showings were like bad seats so I just
decided to wait
this isn't a popular opinion but I don't
care enough anyway
yeah no I I like Star Wars a lot but I
know not if he does what the [ __ ] is
that
you got to shoot that locust right I
think we fought one like that
oh he just disappeared you gotta wait
yeah there is or a beard of bees for
that woman I shot me in the back me down
no I see one he's dead
oh we're just surviving I think it see
the timer until now [ __ ]
we should have guarded those levers
better I guess why is there there
pulling those levers to bring the booger
dudes out oh I'm kind of went to herbs
left to tic tacs
all right [ __ ] [ __ ] that up
creator there oh uh he's charging nice
Wow oh he's still alive looks like a
like a fight without panties just like a
you mean like a but yeah looks just like
a straight-up human butt
watch out that guy's gonna hit the lever
let me tell you about hemorrhoids
I shot him that's [ __ ]
I shot him we got three seconds anyway
we should be fine thank you let's mop up
yep hey say ex really fast over and over
sex say toy boat really fast
toy boy ha ha you said Tybalt nice one
revenge is sweet
oh we're gonna run to Sherry and Jacob
hey how's your campaign going
it's pretty long really bad dialogue you
just freed us looks like you guys saved
the day again huh
I can see your father and you literally
he's coming out of your chest how did
you
yeah I did
and I'm the one that killed him then I
kissed him in that order I don't care
about these peoples you
I just that's right Chris but at least
on that puppy this is between me and him
she's got a gun
go ahead shoot
you have every right to makes easier on
me and Mary if you actually shot him
yeah just promise me you'll survive the
world depends on it who the hell are you
to tell me what to do Tommy you're going
down now don't tell me that any points
the gun at himself we just just
offensive - was it personal he's gonna
do that thing Angelina Jolie does where
she like shoots the bullet rounds and it
goes through all these people's heads
and then hits around don't remember but
it's a really dumb seen that little
cheek thing is a reminder don't ever
talk bad about that how about putting
things at stake that you and me that was
my fourth favorite cheek
gotta go I got I got I know piers knows
a thing about his dick cheeks I know
that game
I killed your father Jake I also have
his foreskin thanks Cherie
hey come here explain this to me outside
of the water temple in ocarina of time
how does water do this go up no it's
like a column that becomes it's like a
stool act stalagmite of water explain
this to me is it not supposed to be
water or maybe it is like you could be
just like it's up there too
this whole place is very confusing the
laminar flow herpes never die we wanna
know what laminar flow is sure is it
gross no just because there's word flow
in it doesn't mean that it's gross
laminar flow is when you like what stop
it
excuse momentum and water to have it
keep its shape you know like sometimes
fountain let's make water and have those
like perfect tubes they look really cool
yeah that's laminar flow triple force I
think it's more of like the properties
of water and the fact that it wants to
stick together because the particles so
they would rather stay together under
those conditions oh sweet I have Jake
over here I have you Garrity hey there's
people up there's a bad [ __ ] thank you
that was nothing
sherry I can do something with your own
some of these mutations are oh sure
look at these two parents coming
together and Perkins parks internet yeah
how's that just like out of nowhere she
just shocked the [ __ ] out of them I just
want to be like Sheree you did something
I am so proud of you my sweat is silver
I got you
I was reloading
look I was doing such a good job
serpentining to no avail
ha ha I got you oh I just watched one of
them kill themselves it's like the
happening I feel a film that has to
happen to them every once in a while
where they just feel like they get no
say in their lives okay so hear me on
this from a game design doing so good
I'm a game design standpoint this parts
actually not that it's fun but
functionally what does this lift
who would ever ride a lift like that
goes in this crazy pattern it
malfunctions ever it doesn't it
logically I don't I know this man is
stopping since like square one but so
hard I still like it to somewhat make
diegetic sense or whatever you want to
say I don't know diabetic senses yeah
also this big ooh I could still have
control this oh we're back a reunion
I felt like that during other Resident
Evil's them yeah like it's the original
one day they had to say like Oswald
Spencer and the architect like there
were rooms there were rooms that like
had Pete whoa it was in like nonsensical
places and I remember being like why
would you actually they justified it by
saying Oz well Spencer he wanted it to
be confusing yeah he was paranoid one to
protect you today
what's the architect's name Trevor i am
i blanking on this it's Joe
[Music]
Oh another friends
you killed my father my name is Inigo
Montoya you killed my father I'm gonna
cut your tooth oh whoa I just hurt you I
don't think it helped most [ __ ]
oh god I just saw this ladder Oh hold -
this go thing is cheap run
got these allowed scammers not do you
think he's all made out of that liquid
thing your time out yeah if you think
more fun oh sure thing yeah movie up oh
my god you have to let me it I know let
me out let me no way we're gonna make
this yeah what did we get like a slow
start in the beginning is your super
debt huh I don't think I was as speedy
as I could
is that could've been yeah - liar oh
right
[Music]
I think we're doing this thing yeah
best circle fast
upsy daisy's baby
sploosh go
oh are you dead shoot him
oh yeah shot a minutes way did you shoot
his hand I shot him in his eye
yeah me too sorry I got like oh [ __ ]
slide hell - oh man I'm doing this in a
really slow way that might have [ __ ]
it up
Oh God marry you
I'm still alive based on my quick
thinking
roll camera just keeps changing angles
look at dark soy sauce Circle Circle
Circle Circle Circle Circle Circle
Circle
Oh s+ let's close does it look like some
sort of Dark Souls boss yes but not good
but yes shoot him Oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ] circle
again got it
this boss fights soft let me end why
won't it let me press it okay got it I
think I think you're good yeah okay all
right whatever
in case of emergency please use the
stairs
if the water temple boss attacking us
does that count as an emergency this
looks like a final boss fight to me I
hope we don't know it's got a heart it's
got a heart on sweet whoa I think we
just shoot him and then hopefully he
exposes that heart
we just face until then I guess show us
your dumb heart dumb-dumb hey I hope you
like grenades but dinner boy
oh he got me I'm not sure where his face
for now yeah yeah
face I don't know I'm gonna go up to him
maybe I can yeah hey Lane maybe I was
gonna go for his like whoa Chester home
[Music]
he's got these like he's got like his
like a pink sock coming out they're
pretty upsetting the head with my rat oh
[ __ ] he's about to I threw a grenade I
don't think it did anything
maybe I am true the wrong spot to this
it's never ever should have done
something coming toward me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah maybe I can mail in or
something
can you pay pal face or something attack
of socks no way
what No
there'll be another stage
all these boss fights have had like 20
stages
which to be fair well I am NOT THERE
mine
he's still alive or he just farted as he
died he released his bowels looks like a
rapture that's calculated he's still
alive
oh sure you can got it I'm in
well
oh [ __ ] now we're dead are we have you
ever died in water in lava before yeah
that's kind of a one-two punch the only
thing worse could be like you falling
into an abyss wasn't enough they were
like let's hope let's drown you and melt
you let's reload everything before we
put lava at the bottom of this water
Wesker died oh [ __ ] that's right Chris
killed him in the [ __ ] volcano the
worst spot speaking of bad boss fights
that was bad the Wesker one oh yeah the
what time events like focus hey hey hey
why am i sideways I love to not be
sideways I crawled up there
all right yeah we got it
okay bright hey hey um did you die
I didn't slide sorry
pillows yeah what is with resident evil
in like I can't wait for seven they're a
good boss fight - oh I've never heard
anything negative about I know but
there's there's one that I dislike is
it's kind of like the East scripted
whereas the rest are goods they're
freeform like reservoirs
go good I breaks the top why did it
start me that far back that's what I
made it through but it's such [ __ ]
not on my screen my screen you died of a
mix of drowning and lava it's
suffocation I guess the coroner couldn't
determine it because your body was all
[ __ ] up yeah calls his death corners
like listen he was like not even what do
you want me to do with this they drown I
really don't know you gave me like two
Bertie's there's not a lot I can you see
them that's not a tooth that's
it says Cheers all right are you gonna
get through here I made it yeah this is
what is happening I thought we both made
it I made it did I not make it I didn't
see I mean I didn't you didn't the game
is [ __ ] up
I didn't slide to be fair I don't think
you need to let's we need to stick by
each other cuz I think the door starts
closing once the first person goes
through I think that's what's happening
is that if we're not close enough
together but you and I were really close
together on that you ready I'm gonna
shoot minutes fat man
okay are you good yeah you there yep
good all right I'm gonna slide okay
sweet hopefully that's the last one
nope shoot this and then go Redmond
Redmond then done I'm gonna slide I
think you have to slide yeah stupid but
I feel like that's what no okay
QuickTime events come and I'm not sure
what hit that button tap that X kiss
that sweet cross God go calm I am about
this sorry
it's acts like nothing at he's in B's
more embarrassed in the shop sorry I
don't know what happened
dude [ __ ] this thing oh my god more of
this no tell there's a sniper I'm
serious we shoot him for a run I don't
run run run my gun okay I can't see the
screen
just poorly-designed a fight if you can
call this a fight I wouldn't I don't
think I was
we'll shoot him in his eyeball
oh my god god I'm so generous I'm so
awesome oh wait no that's you you look
surprised to see me
that can't be good for the coming fight
you have something in your arm what is
what bone is that the humerus oh I think
I'm dead
that's the humerus right the upper arm
bone imagine a spike going through bad
and your bicep in your tricep
squeeze and squeeze them to five squeeze
them like a bag get that kiss that sweet
syringe baby oh I see they're making me
crawl Allah Metal Gear Solid 4 is there
any way it moves faster I know your arm
is pretty much Oh
his arm is pierced by a spike yeah you
guys were waiting for that joke all
series got it
I'm coming I just don't suffocate
there are a few more seconds okay
wait why does stemis cuz you're the one
with the arm wait what was it and he had
to do it was like a super arm strength
potion
oh you were serious like prototype that
game yep oh no way help me oh yeah what
I have a railgun for an arm now I don't
member this I don't think I've ever
played a spiritual boy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh he's dead
wait come here come here come here
god this is awesome alright this game is
made up for come here no no come look at
me look I'm charging up he didn't do it
look who's Captain Awesome now how Chris
doesn't have a comment about my growth
no he doesn't wanna talk about it
a look at krauser from raising before
remember the knife fight oh my god
oh yeah but now he's got like a laser
arms
yeah
I'm actually not sure what I'm doing oh
it's draining my health when I shoot him
well oh [ __ ] yeah I did not know that
Jimmy does spray you candy I don't know
if it's gonna work I'm sure I yeah right
just for the record oh no it's written
never mind never mind it's rechart I
thought I was gonna go up to the first
bar yeah if you can't be great thank you
okay I'm gonna shoot him oh he threw it
up what he threw like a metal thing at
you I feel like I'm supposed to be doing
something else
Oh like I don't know yeah I mean you can
probably shoot him it's not gonna hurt
it's gonna hurt him
yeah yep yep yep Oh can I can I oh I
kicked him [ __ ] any more help yes there
do i I can't even use my inventory right
now I just have this tool room okay I
here come here
I think thanks Krista thing wait Oh is
he dad again for now yeah I feel like
I'm supposed to be doing something yeah
he's just getting smaller every time you
have to you have to kill it when he's in
his cocoon
I think I'm charged up
why Malcolm to charging an order
Oh got him
I'm not the one with the electric oh
[ __ ] okay he's got that growth you can
shoot them with yep come up in this
grenade him well shouldn't I do it when
he's in his cocoon yeah what that wasn't
that wasn't true [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god I
almost killed myself oh wait no press r2
on him press r2 oh I think it might
actually happier than me give me your
soul if we've still got three times
maybe yeah well I used all my ammo
learning how to do this I wish I could
give you mine I don't have anything
besides mine
he's cocoon again yes yep take it up
there I don't even think my legs are
reaching him oh no he's hatching Oh for
[ __ ] sake
oh man I really need to hear ya bright
side I think this is actually the final
boss fight we've said that before though
we see it often
yeah I'm just gonna get points I think
they're not gonna give me ammo at this
point
oh whoa jerk RM issues growth
got it all right he's cocooning I think
[ __ ] wait but we can't get up and we
know a ladder let's shoot him anyway no
no he's not even oh god damn it how is
your home it's not phenomenal but it's
doable
alright I'm gonna go shoot him a bunch
of times
do some kind of like electricity
oh you just stunned me at the I'm down
sorry press bar one if you can post a
circle oh no oh my god god damn it oh
you got me I might have no you killed I
think we've got it under control
do we yeah now I will not oh say we
gotta tell oh wait no this is I don't
even know anymore so give a grenade
launcher still a grenades yeah alright
so when he could could use a grenade
launcher I would say I think he's about
to right now there's one more girl don't
honestly don't even waste your ammo
until you cocoon okay I'll worry about
him
[ __ ] alright he should quick in I used
to create him
yeah all right I'm gonna r2m okay got
him maybe it looks like
I'm gonna back off and heal from it i
recharge health but like [ __ ] do you owe
me to heal you
no I'm good I got half health but yet I
would save your grenades until he's okay
so he's about to hatch right now I don't
think we can Eric can you grenade him
right now because you get it miss
Hatcher I think you just hatched at
least past the system I would save your
health
yeah he's got like two girls you gotta
hit so aim for those things they're
gonna stream
like I said you probably save your ammo
okay
oh he just shot something
Oh Oh God he hit me with one of his
electro balls [ __ ]
I need to recharge gonna let them do
this thing
Oh God oh shoot you can shoot the things
out I'm gonna get some distance between
him and I
I'll go around his side
Oh
he might be cocooning right nope not yet
one more girl oh my god that thing holy
[ __ ]
no Kuni he's good good okay but I need
him yeah alright go stab him maybe one
more after this just following the rule
of three yeah he's got one more girl
alright one more time I think those are
heart yeah I don't know like sis hearts
okay I'm going to kill up all right CEO
meeting he'll you know I'm recharged
done so I'm just getting some distance
he's hatching anyway probably gonna be
coats or parks it's all so cool that was
grenades in there I needed the room
alright here he comes
oh he's spitting goo oh shoot those pods
that it forms
oh [ __ ] I explained it up Oh sick okay
Wayne what no he's got one more thing I
think oh now he's reformed
got it all right get ready Dylan yeah
okay walk that scared the [ __ ] out of me
Kaku in his ass
Eric shoot his ass disasters cocooned is
that sweetgrass wait what the [ __ ] yeah
here Oh God look up cool am oh god oh
god of course a QuickTime event wait got
it
I'm on the ground crawl toward me you
can I'm pressing X furiously it's
actually not that bad
yes
God he's so awesome I can't think of a
time when he's not oh my god down
[ __ ]
just stay down come on just stay with me
you're gonna be okay yep I'm clearly not
gonna be okay bsaa
for the future I know did a real good
thing Thanks
as long as you I don't want to hear it
love me
god you're ugly used to
goddamnit I heard right here I don't
know why I just took it there's one
there
[Music]
do i heal too when I heal you or do I
only heal feels if it's first day to
heals both oh sorry I think I'm gonna
use it I need to go oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh and everyone I don't think I
was at full health I mean you still got
balls with matter oh you weren't you
weren't close enough to shoot this no no
I was at full health
am I supposed to
oh right I don't
Oh got it kid sleep Oh God
terrific kill that guy over
I don't know
oh he punched me yeah just do the wall
I'm getting east god damn it focus on
the what so that's why I was wondering I
think we have to kill him in order for
the wallah go away or am I wrong I don't
think we did it last time I think we ran
away from those guys okay oh yeah you're
right we did get this herb here before
you go okay I love you why is that
three those see the 9u8 immediate
alright
yeah I'll try to focus on those guys Oh
oh my god
this is the one
all right I'm going to jump over
all right so shoot okay yeah we're
shooting the wall it's raining money
might slide [ __ ] you're not good at
I'll shoot the wall you want to keep
that
whoa whoa okay if you can possibly do me
soon yeah because I need more help with
the strength I think while I'm shooting
yeah yeah we're good go it's not over
it's never over it or maybe it is oh
right my arm just go no you're gonna be
okay
[Music]
there one left so good
we out of here in no time put it in the
lap pod just like Armageddon
[Music]
god you're hideous got it we're getting
out of here he's gonna push him in gotta
push him in dropkick him into it
stare at his hand [ __ ] close it
Armageddon god dammit his
[Music]
[Music]
like [ __ ] up huh you can't tell but
I'm giving you a thumbs up
[Music]
peers ease I have to poop
well I played my part in resonable sex
oh my god
like I even care it
yeah that would me
I don't if they gave me a QuickTime
event when I wasn't even on screen to do
that into the water lava you go you had
one more quick time event that entire
cutscene
great now where do I go is there a
helicopter coming oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god I think we beat this
stupid game let's talk about a circus I
got some thoughts as opposed to last
time I played it
all those good memories I did it for the
BSAA
where did he get that did it not fuse
into his mutated arm
I was really fast
hey Mike yeah so that's that all right
sherry and Jake's campaign will be well
we might return to it in a few months I
am stoked for Reverend evil seven all
right so Mara we have a decision to make
now I guess this is a conversation seven
seven seven plays on camera but do you
even want to start an hour of it before
you go to Australia you want to come
back fresh after Australia I could do an
hour I can come back this week okay or a
couple does that game is better pace
than this well let me switch to two so
overall I could do a turn this weekend
where's his game fit into your pantheon
of present evil right where were we at
we were at I was at remake good choice
uh [ __ ] I forget my original order was
it it was remake for four to three and
then this is a toss-up because I think
they're both pretty bad to be honest
with you I had more fun playing six for
the purposes of the show
maybe because sorry got to go back to
the intro ignore this graphic don't look
gotta go
six I had more fun than five maybe it
was the purpose of the show six is just
dumb it's not a great game at all six is
not a great game but it's really
entertaining yeah I felt like five was
boring and there's a ton of fan service
like this I mean it's cool to see Leon
and Chris meet for the first time if I'm
not mistaken yeah
seeing ADA oh so there's a huge thread
that we we're not gonna see because
we're not doing so you do Jacob Cherry's
campaign would you feed all three you do
ADA's like shorter three chapter
campaign huh and you find out that there
were two different ADA's one was a clone
one was Carla or like a clone
essentially she was created by Simmons I
think I don't care but they were dressed
differently so the one that was helping
us was the real later
it's like a soap opera with fire is
involved it is soap opera yeah alright
operas have bioterrorism in some point
normally in like season 13 when it's
really jumping everybody's been in a
coma they've written themselves into a
corner
hey let's miss you O w we have finally
made it through 0-7 we did it I'm
excited I'm excited I hope you guys are
excited because this is actually the
last game in the numbered series we
[ __ ] did it we were supposed to be
here in January it's mid-october yep but
it's been a long fun ride we did it yeah
here we go so seven seven seven seven
seven I avoided spoilers for eight
months I am really eager ten months I am
what month is and there are some like
you have twists but there are some
things if you have not seen about the
game I'm curious to see your reaction to
it very very and you like horror movies
we used to do the dead air the podcasts
are like there's a lot of horror movie
influences in it like poltergeist saw
Texas Chainsaw Massacre there's like a
bunch of different kind of Horrors in
seven and I keep describing to people as
Resident Evil remake in first person
like backtracking through a mansion and
then going to the grounds around it I'm
excited
alright well let's do it next episode is
episode 1 of Resident Evil 7 the
penultimate numbered game in Resident
Evil we'll see you then the last one
this was the penultimate numbered game
no 7 last